[Musique]
ce mercredi 14 décembre le département
participait au comité plénier du Haut
Conseil de la commande publique
organisée dans les locaux de la Chambre
de commerce et d'industrie à Saint-Denis
à l'issue des interventions d'acteurs
locaux de la commande publique la
vice-présidente Béatrice sigismo a
renouvelé l'engagement de la
collectivité dans l'amélioration des
processus d'achat en signant la Charte
relation fournisseur achat responsable
aux côtés du président de l'association
stratégie du bon achat la SBA réunion
c'était déjà engagé en 2010 et
aujourd'hui on renouvelle notre
engagement parce que on a fait vraiment
un parcours comme c'est un ma commande
publique avec
des améliorations apportées avec un
réseau
partenariat sur
une commande publique qui s'adapte
économique de l'île de la Réunion qui a
subi comme vous le savez tous des
conséquences d'une crise sanitaire et
d'une crise économique s'en est suivi
l'annonce des lauréats des Trophées de
la commande publique 2022 le département
c'est ainsi vu décerné le prix de la
chasse socialement responsable
récompensant ainsi l'effort
départemental dans sa dimension sociale
au travers du plan à million d'arbres
pour la Réunion on se voit aussi
remettre le prix de la chasse
socialement responsable ça veut dire que
on a appris que toutes les règles pour
que à travers la commande publique on
dynamise aussi l'accompagnement de nos
publics
à travers les clauses d'insertion et
tout ça en travaillant en intelligence
avec les entreprises après un premier
trophée de la commande publique en 2014
et un autre en 2021 le justement se voit
cette fois récompenser pour son soutien
aux établissements accompagnant les
travailleurs en situation de handicap
[Musique]